hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to riddle school 3 the next
game in the series that I'm assuming
it's gonna take place in a school I
don't know how to get that mouse out of
there so you just gotta live with it for
now
little high school boy that's a tiny
little building with from boarded up
whoo wow we get a whole intro and
everything and some kickass music I like
it
ok is that a duo I thought it was a
doobie riddle school 3 welcome to riddle
school 3 nice little intro you did there
ah this looks familiar
is that mister some Heidi hood Oh mister
soggy
he's a generally lazy teacher who can be
very strict if he wants to be well does
he want to be right now Zach he's always
cold ran cafeteria burning a few days
all flames worse all frozen solid
what yeah that shouldn't be impossible
that's Fred wait was his name spelled
like that before
ok losses whistle smiley she doesn't
blink I got a ruler smiling globe not
make me happy peeling wallpaper mu world
map I don't know where the hell that is
air vent chalkboard
I can't leave holy [ __ ]
this is loud Oh globe ah chewing gum
that's good right what do I do with that
do I combine it with the ruler oh I do I
don't know what that's gonna do but it's
gonna do something yeah yeah yeah no
Fred Zack smiley oh how did how did you
get by the teacher to be able to do that
he's sitting right there
ah ok oh ah logical I don't know I don't
know why but okay I'm totally down for
that what the hell dude why take that
mr. soggy
doosh damn some rubber band
Oh now's my chance the blind we can't
see
I'm just gonna panic and not actually
look for my glasses which I'm going to
take cuz I'm an [ __ ] apparently that
wasn't a very sharp idea actually it was
kind of blurry very funny I get it okay
all right then library Oh animated yes
well then hello everybody I didn't do
anything
I just walk into every room and
instantly shout my name
hello everybody okay this one's blue how
to read read this this book is borrowed
by George that's adorable I think I'm
done reading now and forever oh I just
want it pink palm book by binky Fanny
poems five penny fine five pennies find
them all every pennies in the hall rs3
secret don't beat this game two times
straight or else you'll meet a certain
fate key deep in the jungle you'll find
a key guarded by creatures that watch
from the trees monkeys okay so do I need
to be the game twice in a row huh
trysting I might try that if I have
enough time port face on Oh pad directly
the toenail that's not that's not your
toenail as it was paid for by Kirsch
okay how about this one
sonic is awesome I don't know about that
how are you mr. Reid I feel kind of
depressed I'm a librarian and I can't
even read well I can read but only big
print books you see my eyesight is like
a stuffed monkey doll or whatever the
hell I said how about these someone
else's glasses oh my god it's impossible
who knew glasses could work in such a
way is a free bookmark faith thank you I
feel like you would have given that to
me even if I didn't give you the glasses
but okay I'll be on my way thank you sir
penny they're all in the hall it said so
that poem was probably correct
so there are pennies in the hall there's
another one no no no woman's room what
look at me like that do that hey come on
don't judge me all right fine
supply closet Oh Stabler no tissues no
trashcan no calculators no scissors
rulers textbooks no pages a dime how
about a bookmark oh how about I combine
the bookmark ah
it's a foot and a half oh it's genius oh
that's so smart I mean I'm so smart I'm
the greatest yeah hell yeah I'm the best
all right where do you come from a class
I'd say and or my mother let's see
haha okay which teacher did you just oh
sorry I meant to read this I sorry it
was going on and I was blanking out on
there uh I came from mr. soggy
completely against coffee I remember
when he told us the story about coffee
he spilled 10 full mugs copy on his
clothes in the first grade and everybody
teased him
they called him coffee SOG or something
like that he hated that didn't like them
wow this is a story okay bye then
apparently okay I don't think there was
anything else to go on there so I'm just
gonna go through the rest of the place
and if I need to come back to it I will
whoa there's a second floor ah so we get
to have a whole bunch of fun fun flung
them on them Lum Lum Lum hello can I get
some macaroni
oh no apparently not agging okay
nevermind he's got to be something else
here miss munch ah like some chocolate
pudding okay I don't want to spend my
money just yet you're fatter than the
Sun oh you can live without you're proud
of yourself okay so now I need to go
upstairs because I've checked around
here I see Bea oh there's a layout oh
hey how you doing I'm gonna get you
pudding I just need a dollar to be able
to do that so which one doesn't belong
okay weird
how many pennies have I gotten so far
three so there's got to be two more
pennies oh there's another one right
there
leaping from window per hitted it I
don't think that I would be doing that
but okay oh how you doing mrs. flask are
you okay he's a switch or a button to
work need to make a button doesn't have
to be big slightly larger than a
pistachio nut huh so it needs a switch
how do I get a switch I don't know I got
I'm gonna explore the rest of the entire
building first and then I'm gonna figure
out exactly what I mean come one get me
out of this locker
there's Ritchie help me out give me
money this combination
I can ever remember well how am I
supposed to help you I haven't written
down mrs. odd verbs rum tell I need to
get out of here
okay alrighty then little strange but
okay hi again oh it's my old friend
alright bread comes in beaver spit
bathroom stinks
let's see always a mess uh okay doesn't
want to clean I don't think he wants
anything to do wait there was a shiny
quarter underneath is yeah I just want
that underneath your but I want to get
under your butt is what I'm trying to
say here
okay so missus off and that's the last
penny I believe anyway he okay ooh that
one's different
oh nice and a nickel and a cone I have a
fish attached to it okay carrots are
people do I don't think so there's a
locked in light out she must be so she's
in the lounge
ah so if I go back to the lounge will
she actually want to talk with me maybe
hello miss adverb about Ritchie uh hi I
beat that stuffing out of him oh you're
happy about that okay how about uh he's
stuck in his locker Gann do you think I
should go to my classroom and look for
the combination yes you definitely
should wow he actually listened who
would have thought about that I should
probably leave - okay bye have a good
day actually teaching school that would
be lovely
chlorophyll for $200 I need more money
yeah I don't have enough
money to something behind anything over
here no oh there might be something in
the cabinets ooh that looks slightly
broken maybe I can break it no whole lot
of nothing blah blah hold out a dick
there nothing there
maybe the drawer knew how about this one
I got a nickel okay so I'm getting
closer but I need a lot more money if
I'm gonna be able to get what I need I
got that nickel so I'm good okay so now
if I go back upstairs the Locker might
be wait
Oh mrs. adverb that's right hello found
the combination to Ritchie's Locker
let it go doesn't say blah bowls all
right nothing else here okay
nothing else there all right wobbles oh
oh maybe it's maybe it's like boobies
when you put it into a calculator and
you turn it upside down you got it you
got to do it upside down so ha blah
Buhl's if you turn that upside down it's
bubbles yes
I'm smart give me money give me money
fill egg trees at my name I didn't know
about that okay ah yes it was upside
down the whole time thanks buddy
thanks man by the way I'm collecting
buttons
okay thank you all righty then
okay but least I can go into not miss
flasks and go downstairs into the new
classroom and now that one's gonna be
open so hopefully there's gonna be
something in there that I need miscount
Wow ah how ironic that you hate monkeys
okay I got I got the keyboard thing
which might be able to turn on the
button making machine here how about a
little bit of this action huh Boinky
second work yay oh ah I'll take that
thank you it's a start you're a start
I'll take that and be on my way and sell
it to Ritchie again wherever the hell he
went off to okay whatever you need
pudding is he in the janitor's closet
for no reason okay goodbye ha there he
is okay Ritchie hey you want a button
give me money money money money yes
please thank you money Oh your last
quarter I need one more quarter I need
one more quarter how am I gonna get it I
have no idea oh I haven't got in the
bathroom oh I totally forgot about that
urinal urinal urinal stall toilet paper
I'll take that thank you very much I
don't know why I need it maybe if I go
to the janitor maybe he wants some
toilet paper okay so the janitor said
that he could hear the plumbing but if
the plumbing is actually broken then
maybe
ah here we go and flush it flush it yeah
yeah I'm doing it I'm a smarty lettuce
card look at me
oh he hurt it huh how's that noise
oh okay ah so he's gonna be there for a
while and then I can get hopefully it's
not just a dime underneath this but it
was a quarter it was it was a quarter
okay
so now I can afford some pudding only I
have $200 chocolate budding blaze thank
you very much yes count it's enough
thank you thank you
whoa that is a lot of chocolate pudding
enough for uh big man upstairs all right
got your cover buddy let's see how quick
you move for this one come on bring it
on
oh gee oh jeez oh okay
Oh No ah that's amazing
I love that oh okay all right what are
we doing down here
ah that seems to be a problem
thanks chub really appreciate that but I
don't know why I needed to be in here
all right so now in the office mrs.
Moo's is I'm gonna help you give me all
your money
ah okay how about something else
insolent oh whoa what huh Oh wake him up
I don't see it i I don't know what I I
don't know what I pressed send ears in
this machine whoo
I've ruled with gum on it no never mind
potato I'm awesome whoa that worked
I'm awesome it worked the answer was
that I was awesome which I should have
known nice nice nice dude take it it's
all yours buddy get out of here you
earned it congratulations
way to go you're a champion
awesome man you did it good job way to
go
awesome he did it and then I am out of
your correct
okay so that's all I need right bada
bing ba boom I'm done okay
is that everything am I finally free I'm
finally free I could have just waited
again I can just wait until the end of
the night and gone home on the school
bus without wooden bed is fun and we are
free oh do I have a car
oh I guess I'm in high school so why not
nice nice nice I thought that was like a
weed pipe or something
[Music]
nice
Oh delightful
and there you have at the end a riddle
school 3 a vast improvement over in
school 1 & 2
definitely more animation and more
interesting puzzles and more
coordination between the items which I
thought was really cool so thank you
everybody so much for watching
actually wait hang on it said it said
there might be something for beating it
as hello ah oh that's right he said he
wouldn't get out until pigs flying
thusly pigs are flying oh that's nice so
I'm gonna I mean I might I might just
blast through this game again to see if
there's actually something for me at the
end of it so a poor pig way way I'll see
you in a bit just in case I do or if
there is something okay so I just got
the key in record time by the way it was
very very quick to be able to do that
also I don't think there's anything else
that I need to do or anything like that
so I'm about to beat it for a second
time so if something gonna happen it's
gonna happen now I don't know how or why
or when or if it's gonna happen at all
or if that thing was just a lie but
maybe it would
what oh oh oh hey whoa you've been
possessed by monkey doll
oh well that's terrifying Oh
horrifying Oh God jeez Wow okay Wow
all right then those horrifying so that
is the secret ending if you beat it
twice in a row that was actually pretty
cool I like that a lot
for reminded me of ionizer Fridays but
this was before five times two Freddy's
was even made it was cool so anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye